everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk author of
crush it book calm and I made that big
statement in the book you know social
media equals business and I promise to
explain it to a bunch of you and so I've
decided to make a video to do that the
reason I put that in my book is that I
feel so many people think that social
media is a tactic or is a nuance I guess
the way I think people think you know
mustard is just like you know on top of
the hot dog your hot dog is your
business and that social media is maybe
a mustard at best and I guess what I
want to really talk about is that social
media which oh by the way was called web
2.0 a year ago and oh by the way Mott
and everybody out there is going to be
called media in a year it is a business
in itself see I spend 15 hours 12 hours
10 hours a day in the trenches what you
guys call social media what it is is
customer service it's actually caring
about somebody it's actually being in
the trenches and listening to the
customer see what I know what I know
very well is that most companies are
full of crap they want to sell stuff
they don't wanna care they want to make
pretend they care they want to make
pretend they work hard for the customer
customer service they'll put it in the
booklet but it's not culture and DNA and
so what I know is that social media
which really translates to complete
transparency no more hiding in the
shadows what I know is that social media
is going to expose businesses that
customer service that the word of mouth
of one is gonna screw with corporate
America and with businesses that the
power of one consumer has never been
bigger and will never ever be the same
as it used to be and because of this
understanding and grasping the fact that
you have to engage and care about your
customers what you guys call social
media is now the backbone and always has
been the backbone of building a
successful business but we now can scale
are caring using social media and so
what I mean by this is very simply if
you're an accountant or a lawyer or if
you sell peanut butter or if you're a
brand manager or if you're you know a
district manager for a shoe
or if you were an entrepreneur that's
selling a service or a product you are
in the social media business my friends
you are in the business to actually care
about your audience to give them what
they want and most importantly not to
talk but to listen and so thus social
media is business